[Music]
in so what happened news what the hell
submitted by ash ketchup Oh like Ash
Ketchum mm-hmm but like ketchup yeah
yeah mm-hmm you know ketchup is the
brand name for capsule I didn't know
that thank you
I don't know what I don't know what the
brand name isn't it know that Heinz was
a brand name Heinz is I feel like you've
what ha catsup at first what's the
difference between ketchup and catsup
the ketchup ketchup kids I'm in way over
my head
they do taste different they do to me
they do like in Mexico if you got kept
ketchup and then if you that's it like
that soup with like more watery like
more like not so teeny I feel like the
ketchup or whatever in every country
probably has a slight taste very yeah
okay then they also sell like the Heinz
one and then it's like more vinegary oh
I don't know maybe I'm tripping I like
being a curry ketchup welcome to our
ketchup podcast a rapper gets over five
hundred thousand dollars worth of
jewelry stolen from his car while eating
at Cracker Barrel the dichotomy of
having $500,000 in jewelry and eating
yet cracker burn were like hardly
anything is more than ten bucks it's
like I mean I'm rich but the pancakes
real yeah but that's rapper stereotype
you know it's like you don't leave the
hood you just stay there but you still
want win that's proper I know you're
having a G Wagen Oh see it's like you're
a target man yeah so they put a sign on
his cry says please Rob me like I got
money and you live in the jewelry in
your car he probably has it in the
[ __ ] cupholders just filled with
jewels and [ __ ] sick-looking order your
sweet tea at cracker brother like not
got it
I dropped my own diamonds and I just
hold my drink mix them up it was like
and there's way more in the car alright
so this rapper it was young Dolph heard
a young dog he got his car shut up my
day arrived like over a hundred is he
from Florida he had a bulletproof car
and they got shot up like insane about
people hate his guts
yeah it got me so mad we should've his
carne lizard like hey I'm gonna get
another shot at that dude some people
out there have bulletproof cars and they
just drive him around because they're
paranoid this guy has a reason for
having a bulletproof car actually there
were two attempts at his life in 2017
was it gang related videos brat beef
yeah because I'm not sure the funny
thing is like the rappers today if this
was the 90s
they would be called something that is
not a lot to be said today but it starts
with the F word it ends with the G ah oh
I like that word yeah but but you know
what I'm talking about right watch when
the F and ends with the G took me a
minute yeah I mean look at what he looks
like look he does not look like a thug
from our era no he looks like it's he
looks like he starts with it F and ends
with the G the way that he dresses I
like like back in our day like thugs
look bug today thugs look like they sell
ice cream yeah they look like characters
that you created and I'm in a massively
multiplayer online game I'm sure I'm
sure these gangsters yeah me too and
it's just the the clothing choice does
now represent the thugs and army he
looks like he works at a at a ghetto
carnival at the [ __ ] cotton candy
booth he looks like the the pink in blue
does look like a Kennedy
kid-like bought him in fortnight like
this character designed the fortnight
exactly the evolution of gangster
changes to because even from our days
before that whitey Bulger's they used to
wear the whole suit why I don't see you
they all like intimidating you know what
you think from like zoo chanting one
black Italian mom was like but it was
all intimidating when I see this guy I'm
like I'm gonna kick his ass but then
you'll kill me no but you just you know
they got the hammer on him yeah it's
like I don't see a guy on a pink shirt
and my blue teeth and think he's a
gangster yeah cuz what I think of
gangsters I go oh I don't want to be his
friend that much I hope well I do if
he's protecting me but I don't know you
might like just bite me one day no but
this dude is like oh yeah he looks kind
of friendly like I feel like I could
where I could go out and like ride
tandem bikes with this dude or something
finally go right Tanner bikes I'm like
yo let's go play volleyball and stuff
you know like then finish up with a
tandem bike right he looks like he just
has a yo-yo and as populated sadly as
we're saying is a yo-yo I agree
he's got a kendama and [ __ ] Oh only
that's how they fought the rap wars was
with yo-yo babbles I mean that's what
breakdancing and and all that stuff was
supposed to be for yeah yeah I've said
this before but I think if it was all
with water guns would be great like they
just get each other really wet and like
who ever got wet or loses yeah turned
into that porno it does it does just
imagine these hard rappers like going
super soakers on each other like hard
water balloons
nothing is a gate Tolo is like hugging
themselves in the bathtub I got lost in
your eyes scary this guy looks like a
skip an ambassador the way he got robbed
in a Cracker Barrel we can't defend em
estroux here we go so this dude he was
in Atlanta we called him everything in
the book we did spelled what we would
call them I'm sure he's a really nice
guy unfortunate because no one should
well hold on so the police are saying
that this case is unusual in a number of
ways because surveillance footage shows
the thieves approaching his car three
separate times the first time they say
that it's possible that they entered the
car without vandalizing it and then the
third time they smashed the window and
made off with all these things and then
they escaped in a silver cart but the
thing is it was really weird because
when the when young Dolph when he got
out of his car to go inside Cracker
Barrel
[Laughter]
you guys are burning someone who got has
been shot at twice tail lights flashed
on and off and then a couple of minutes
later they watch two more times so
they're saying that that's interesting
job yeah like what if he he lets us all
have it because feel like he was like he
was like unlocking the car for them like
that I don't know that's what police are
looking into because so what they did is
that he's like oh no I got robbed I had
so much jewelry in there when he didn't
have nothing no he did it or I don't
know maybe but he says that they made
off with a Richard Mille watched worth
oh no they're expensive yeah darling
million-dollar watch two hundred and
thirty thousand dollars a patek philippe
watch that cost eighty five thousand yep
yeah it's the they're like the lower
level of that bribe Richard mail watches
that are like they're originally were
like a million at you and then they
started introducing that economy line
and then those are the two hundred
thousand yeah so it's like it's like the
what the c-class yeah it's crazy though
yes of n this other watch how do you
pronounce it that's it Philippe
that's pretty high up there yeah so that
one is $85,000 and then to diamond
chains worth fifty seven thousand and
twenty seven thousand and in addition to
that they also stole two pairs of
cardiac sunglasses worth $24,000 seven
hundred dollars a clock firearm an Apple
MacBook oh god knows where I draw the
line I've had ear plug and a I didn't
know he was rich until you said hair
pies I don't care about
they're like air pods for the Pentax
weaver Hornets and then a pirelli
backpack they're taking everything
yeah a backpack and then also two
thousand dollars in cash this guy has
like his whole bank in his car he that's
a lot to leave in a car no maybe he just
did a photo shoot or song sheet or
something that's dumb dude what how cool
is that he has an article out in the
news about how he got robbed from his
car and he has that much [ __ ] money
in there that is the most ballers I
never hear about young dog anything
related to rap music exact always draw
something else yeah give me shy
absolutely not
seize publish this is smartest boy like
look man don't worry about music music
does itself in the news about violence
not always playing every time I've heard
about him it's never been about yo young
dogs got a hot song out you should
listen to it yeah it's just things like
do you think that young golf sir um no I
don't I can't say that I think anything
about his music I don't even have any
frame of reference to say it's good or
bad I see yeah true I never heard it's
like wishing about toys though his whole
thing was about like dolphins and sea
world you know because his name is
Adolph Thornton Hitler sounds more
gangster Adolf sounds like an
interesting name for black baby
Yeah right your name hey that's just a
weird thing oh this is Adolf I thought
his name was dolphin cuz he probably
laughed like one she was from Miami was
he adopted by German parents I know I
ate all these brother's name is
bratwurst
that's crazy yeah yeah that's a lot of
money that's pretty ballin though half a
million dollars a million dollars into
whales just be well you
I know that means just thinking of this
comes out that he set it up and it's
just like I think that's what they're
applying a little bit come on I'm
implying too because of the publicist
thing I just think it's it's when you
get your name out in the news like that
it's pretty dark oh listen I'm gonna
probably look up his music cuz I'm like
now right here he is
yeah that's I'm saying it's genius I
wonder if his thing is or like dolphin
shows yeah I'll pull that flipper out on
you have you guys ever heard whales like
whales in the water no like just what
Dory didn't sound like a horn like it
does but it's [ __ ] crazy man so I was
scuba diving in Hawaii years ago thank
you I'm screwed I believe I was being
pulled along by this scooter thing which
is tight like you'd like I want to try
those really [ __ ] dope yeah that's
really cool so you like point in any
direction you go towards it and then all
of a sudden I heard whales with my own
ears like in the dislike sonar called
yes like whatever the [ __ ] whatever
that noise is I heard it with my own
ears not like a recording for once it's
[ __ ] not crazier than the recording
it's well it it sounds like that but
it's just like you're like holy [ __ ] the
idea that it's like near you through
near manual life right yeah real life
that's it was crazy
could you also feel it's that you're in
the water can you also feel this oh no
no no but it was really cool that's me
and I'll swimming next to like a big
[ __ ] turtle he's like right next to
me like we're jealous I like big turtles
yeah
[Music]